(electro music)
- My mother swore to her dying days
that my first words were mama,
dada, resistor, capacitor.
(laughs)
I don't know if they had geeks back then
but I was probably one of them.
(electro music)
There is a resurgence,
the 20- and 30-somethings
have discovered analog
audio and they like it.
(electro music)
There is no question that
cassettes are making a comeback.
(electro music)
We are in the last cassette
factory in the United States.
This company duplicates audio cassettes
and loads blank audio cassettes.
We're like a printing press.
They send us the audio,
graphics that they want,
they specify if they want it in a box
and we put it all together.
National Audio Company has been
around since about 1968, 69.
(plastic clinks)
When we first got into duplicating
it was mostly small runs,
the occasional band,
some special order things.
And then, about four or five years ago,
there was a sudden change.
(increasing electronic note)
Every garage band you can imagine
showed up at our doorstep
wanting cassettes.
2015 was probably our biggest year
and this year is without question
on target for exceeding it.
(electro music)
Analog brings a sense of warmth
that is not present in digital.
(electro music)
The download is so
temporary and so passing.
You know, it's there and, it’s
okay, you listen to it
and you enjoy it, but you have
nothing to go back and look at.
The fact of holding it in your hand
seems to be one of the
drawing cards for the cassette,
and then for the older people
would be the nostalgia thing.
(electro music)
I think the cassettes have
made a permanent return.
Shouldn't have gone
away in the first place.
But they did, and now they're back.
(electro music)
My biggest concern is to pass
this on to somebody else.
Yes, there's other people
that know how to do this,
most of them are my age.
So I need to teach and
train younger people.
I wanna see National
Audio continue for as long
as there are tapes to be made.